see but we'll move on to the the point
that I was just making there and I think
the perhaps lack of understanding about
how you view crypto specifically Bitcoin
relative to markets a safe haven or a
hedge doesn't necessarily have to be
rising when markets go down yeah I think
a lot of people confuse safe haven and
non correlation right and so a
non-correlated assets just means that
the value drivers are different right
you see stocks or other assets and the
traditional markets are driven by GDP
interest rates etc bitcoins not driven
by that bitcoin is a artificially capped
supply asset misterben by demand and
demand continues to increase and so over
time you expect supply and demand
economics to play out so sometimes you
could have Bitcoin rising when markets
rise sometimes it could go down that's
positive correlation it can also be
negative but what you're saying is
remember what the drivers are here and
they're different things
absolutely Bitcoin over a long period of
time it's been a non correlated asset
and what I think is exciting about that
is when we see times of global
instability geopolitical uncertainty
things like coronavirus etc stocks bonds
gold etc kind of do what you expect them
to do Bitcoin doesn't do that and so the
fact that it doesn't go up is not bad
it's actually it's a non-correlated
assets oh it's doing exactly what it's
supposed to do for your portfolio which
is exactly why we think investors should
have it in their portfolio critics would
say though that hang on a second
you're telling me to add it to my
portfolio surely I want it to be doing
sort of the opposite thing when when
markets are going down yep again as long
as it is preserving your wealth or
increasing it that non correlation makes
it a safe haven asset right you don't
want to have everything in your
portfolio have the same value drivers
that non correlation actually reduces
the overall risk of the portfolio
Bitcoin has served that purpose for many
many years now we think that it will
continue to do that into the future so